first time in franchise history the
Raptors are going to the NBA Finals how
did you approach this fourth-quarter
comeback just one possession at a time
you kept fighting all game he was down
seven point
we call calls we're going on our way but
we just kind of striving and striving
you know when I was on that [ __ ] and I
started a four-quarter my teammates did
a great job we're picking up that lead
after game five you told me that you
didn't know how to beat the Bucks four
times in a row because you had never
done it and now you have what were the
changes that this team made after the
first two games of the series I think
we're more aggressive on the defensive
end now obviously we made shots guys
that was confident in knock down shots
you shared a moment with the Otteson to
the kupo at midcourt what did you have
to say to him just one of them
congratulations to God he got a lot
better and just the key working finally
your thoughts on the upcoming challenge
that the defending champion warriors be
presented oh man like you just said hit
a Champions so we got to go in have a
mental focus and you know enjoy the
moment to take the challenge
congratulations Kauai go celebrate